en 1986 le centre de formation
d'apprentis de la Chambre de métiers de
l'artisanat des Côtes-d'Armor a été le
premier établissement français à
proposer des formations de niveau Bac à
Bac + 2 il accueille et forme sur ces
deux campus de Dinant et de Ploufragan
les futurs professionnels et salariés de
l'artisanat
aujourd'hui avec 12 filières de
formation et 52 diplômes du CAP à la
licence professionnelle le centre de
formation d'apprentis offre des choix
d'orientation et de qualifications
multiples
chaque année 2000 jeunes intègrent le
CFA et font le choix de l'apprentissage
pour répondre aux attentes et aux
exigences professionnelles des
entreprises le CFA se dotent de plateau
technique performant et investi
régulièrement dans de nouveaux
équipements pédagogiques
portes ouvertes mercredi de
l'apprentissage participation à des
salons accueille des collèges le centre
de formation d'apprentis agite également
sur plusieurs fronts pour assurer la
promotion des métiers de l'artisanat et
l'information sur les formations par
apprentissage auprès des jeunes et des
familles
80% des jeunes en apprentissage trouvent
un emploi à l'issue de leur formation
outils de transmission des savoir-faire
l'apprentissage est en effet une
formidable pépinière de futurs salariés
pour les entreprises artisanales
c'est aussi dans ce vivier que l'on
retrouve bon nombre de repreneurs
d'entreprises artisanales
plus largement un artisan sur deux est
issu de l'apprentissage